hey everybody welcome a lot of coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and the project
that we've been working on for so long
since at least January has finally
launched so if you want to see the live
version of the site it's at Franciscan
dot edu which I'll type right now in the
live chat so you must start out by
telling you just a little bit about the
launch and how things went and then
we're gonna take a look at the Trello
board where I've been tracking you know
everything really from all the extra
features that I want to add and all the
bugs that people have found and then I
have found we're gonna do a little
triage all right which means we're gonna
figure out which things on the Trello
board which tasks are most important it
should be done first and then we're
gonna try to get as many of those things
done as we can in about an hour
so I do have a meeting later on so we
have a hard cap on how long this stream
can go of course I will answer your
questions as we go we use the Pomodoro
timer for those of you who are watching
for the first time I am a full-time
front-end developer for a small
University we have just built the main
website for the University live over the
course of a long time and you're getting
a glimpse of my day-to-day work
I don't rehearse this this is what I'm
actually doing for living and so I will
make mistakes and please call me out on
it and I'll do my best to explain what
I'm doing as I go along it's not really
a tutorial though so don't feel bad if
you get lost just you know ask questions
it's totally fine let's see hey see a
lot of people saying hi hey good to see
you hey or I should say you're good to
see you
all right let me alright let me first
just take I'm gonna set a time or two
I'm just gonna take a few minutes and
I'm gonna tell you about how the launch
went since I didn't dream it because
it's a little bit crazy so basically
this is how things went down last week
at some point last week or the week
before it was society that we would try
to launch on Wednesday okay I was asked
to give the earliest possible time that
I thought we could launch and I said
okay Wednesday is good I knew I wouldn't
be ready by Monday and I wanted to give
myself a little buffer in case something
went wrong so I said okay let's take
Tuesday and Wednesday it is definitely
didn't want to launch on a Friday cuz
things go wrong on a weekend then I have
to to work so Wednesday we go for launch
there was some issues where we had to
verify that we own the domain with
Google but there were some issues with
the IT department and they were
wondering to know well would how would
the verification affect G suite and with
that somehow give the website access to
some G sweet stuff so once we got all
that sorted out on Thursday I came into
work and I went over with the the people
and I T we sat down we changed all the
DNS information and then over the course
of that day slowly we saw the all the
DNS stuff get updated because sometimes
it takes a while got it all updated got
everything running on Google App Engine
and the site started to work and I
started to get messages from people
saying hey I found this link then it
doesn't work or where's this piece of
content I can't find it so it wasn't
really that bad to be honest with you it
was the response was overall like posit
nobody nobody
came talk to me directly or anything and
said they don't like the website we did
have some students
well one student on Facebook maybe a few
students on Facebook said that they
didn't like certain parts of the site
otherwise though not too bad
so overall really happy there were
several people actually came up to me
that day and said congratulations and
they loved the site so that was really
cool
no like major issues aside didn't crash
nothing crazy like that just some broken
links and things so that's what mostly
what I've been going the one through the
only weird issue that I have that I
haven't been able to figure out is that
occasionally when I deploy to Google App
Engine the build just weird things break
so the logos won't show up or certain
pages would just cause an error and then
if I just rebuild and redeploy it works
so what I'm done instead and if
anybody's interested I can show you how
we've done this with App Engine is I set
up some some scripts in my packet
package.json to do a test build and
deploy or it will deploy an instance to
Google App Engine but it won't point the
domain to that instance so I can go to
just that custom URL which it would it
shows me whenever the build and
deployment succeeds make sure everything
works first and then do a real deploy
with that same build okay so that's my
deployment step now which is to be
honest with you that's how it should be
done I think that way there's this
in-between step of you know your
development environment is local and
then there's this test environment and
then production so that's the flow now
it was actually pretty simple once I
found the documentation to figure out
how to do that so I can I can show you
that in a second but basically that's
how everything when not too bad the only
stressful thing is just trying to figure
out what to do first because a lot of
times I'll have multiple people
messaging me and talking to me about we
want this done or that done and do
trying to like handle all those things
coming in while I'm working on other
things is not overwhelming but it's just
you know challenging right okay I see a
lot of people saying hi I just want to
say hey everybody I'm gonna set a 25
minute timer at the end of that timer
I'm gonna go to the live chat I'm gonna
answer your questions and check out what
you've been saying so I see yeah
somebody's song keeps saying hi a lot so
I'm just gonna say hi to you since
you're really excited about that okay
let's see all right timer is set I'm
gonna share my screen now and let me
show you first I'm gonna show you that
script since I just talked about it I'm
gonna show it to you I don't know if
this would apply to anybody if you're
not using Google App Engine I'd like to
go through maybe on a stream one day
we're on a recorded video and kind of
show you the flow of how everything's
set up like a big overview but for now
this is what I've done hopefully you can
see that let me know if it's too small
for now we have our our test deploy
which actually runs a build first so it
does our build step which is just next
build right and then it does a loop so
test deploy it does a g-cloud app deploy
with a no promote flag so that means
it's not going to automatically point
the URL to the latest version which it
normally would do all right so the step
would then be do this go to the URL that
it tells me it spits launched this
instance to make sure that it works and
then I can run deploy right which is a
g-cloud app deploy if for some reason I
needed to just do things really fast
maybe an emergency change I could just
run a build deploy which would build and
deploy write to the live version
immediately this is what I was doing at
first and it didn't always work out so
it wasn't like catastrophic but you know
there was a time where I deployed
something before I came into work when I
was still at home and didn't realize
that a certain section of the site
wasn't working anymore and then when I
got to work I realized that you know but
there was I don't know maybe around an
hour of time that a section of the site
wasn't working so I'm definitely gonna
stick with this now and just hit those
sections of the site that I know have
been affected so mainly some things on
the homepage and things on faculty list
pages those are the only areas that I
know have been affected so far okay all
right so now let me show you our Trello
board and this will be the last thing we
do before we actually get started so I'm
gonna try to zoom in and show you this
is what I was working on right before I
started the stream so I just finished
the Pomodoro session with this and I'm
just working on a student here ran some
some scans and found a bunch of lengths
and stuff super helpful and I forwarded
me all the info so I grabbed it all and
just made a checklist of it and I'm just
going through and checking some of these
broken links a lot of them I had already
fixed by fixing like previous issues so
right now it's just a matter of checking
these links making sure they work now
and then checking them off so I'm almost
through that one
I don't know that that'll be that
exciting for a stream or informative so
let's check out some of the other things
we have I mainly want to look at these
two areas because I've already sorted
through what I think are really
important things and put them in here so
we're just gonna look at the ones that
are assigned to me so they have my
little my image right there we just
looked at these links so the in progress
column is going to be the most important
things right now make any socratic ation
pages let's check out what's in here I
don't even remember this looks like
they're broken links education okay you
know what these edits
I got these from someone else that works
here at the University earlier today
a lot of these are just text edits so
that's all it's not really going to
involve coding so we're gonna skip that
for now this testing I've mainly been
having my one of my student workers work
on this and now there's a large list of
things that need worked on that might be
a decent candidate let's see I do want
to research using algo Leah for the
search because I'm not satisfied with
the way the search results are coming in
right now so if anybody has experience
with algo Leah let me know what you
think of it if you had a good experience
bad experience if you have any advice
for the best way to go about doing that
please let me know I think it's worth it
yeah loli is a paid service if you want
to be able to use all the features Wow I
have a lot of viewers right now hey
everybody please if anybody's a new
viewer you're not sure what's going on
please feel free to ask questions I may
not get to it for a little while I'm
running this timer but I imagine there's
probably a lot of first-time viewers
right now so in about 20 minutes I'm
going to do a little question-and-answer
session if you can stick around till
then I'll answer any questions that you
have okay so I'd rather not do research
on the stream so that's probably out
let's see that's so shows neutral links
all right you know what these are all
not that exciting so here's what we'll
do let me let me go through this really
quick oops not this one this stuff and
let's see if there'd be something a
little bit more exciting in here when
you go to the Search tab without
searching anything the top search option
is unclick Abul
all right let's check that out that's
kind of a weird thing I'm not really
sure what it means all right so my
student worker reported this bug let's
check out what the bug is and let's see
if we can fix it all right so let me I'm
gonna start up my there we go I'm gonna
start up and rock this is gonna let you
check out the site as we're working on
it you can see the site live now if you
want but also you can click on the link
I just paste it in there if it doesn't
work when you click it copy and paste it
in your browser and that should work but
you'll be able to click around on the
site inspect it with your dev tools you
know whatever you want I'm gonna go to
well first let's go to the site so I'm
gonna go to the local host version and
see if we can replicate it here if not
we'll go to the live version so let's go
to the search page I'm not actually even
sure how the my student worker got to
the search page without clicking on a
search but regardless okay so we're on
the search page we haven't searched for
anything and now let's try to click this
ok alright so this seems to be the issue
that if you try to use the top search
bar when you're on the search page a
search does not occur okay what is
alright let me share with you the couple
of solutions that are going through my
head right now okay
number one we could just take away the
search option in the top if we're on the
search page that's an option there's
really no need to have more than one
search on the search page you know what
else I'm also going to assume that the
search on the side here doesn't work
let's check that out and that is the
case okay so neither search option works
on the search page so we could try to
get them to work or we could remove them
now that there's two of them to remove I
don't know if I want to remove two that
might actually be more work than just
fixing this so let's look into the code
and see why this isn't working I think
the reason is going to be because the
the way these work depends on a route
change and since no route change is
happening right because we're already on
the search page that's that's why this
isn't working but there is something I
actually wanted to implement so I'm kind
of glad this came up I want to implement
it so that the search will look here at
the address bar you might not be able to
see it it's small but it'll look at the
search query here and automatically
search so that if a person bookmarked a
search they could come back and see the
same search now all this may not even
matter if we go with a boliya but for
now I don't know how soon we're gonna go
without Golia if at all so I think it
might be worth it to implement this
let's see so we need to check out our
search page and you know what let's see
let's see where that card is for the
search cuz I do I believe I had it on
here let's look over here
Wow let me let me do it let's do a
search for the ad search euro search
page lot of did I not do this hmm
all right I'm not gonna keep looking for
that I thought I already had a card for
that I guess not
it's possible I just made a github issue
for it instead but I'm not gonna do that
let's see I'm gonna I'm getting some
feedback from you all about this so I'm
just gonna go live chat now John Hanson
says the side search menu will fail the
search term if if the search page route
is there Michael Creole says why not
make the search bar components so that
no matter where it is it acts the same
that's not a bad idea I don't know if we
do that right now
I don't know if all the time for to do
that but that's actually not a bad idea
first thing let's go to our search page
and see what we have going on see how
difficult this is going to be to do okay
all right so on our search page let's
see our search term it's probably going
to determine what we search right so
most likely need to grab what's in the
URL and put it into our state under
search term so let's see component did
my own create a search looks like we're
already doing some things with search
and we're already getting when your
location search but are we already
getting the search term interesting oh
you know what
I think I know what the problem is so
this happens when a component did mount
right when we're here on the page
already this this page component is
already mounted so when we change this
it doesn't change the state of that
component so that component doesn't
rerender we don't get this doesn't run
again so that's our problem right now
hmm
all rights
this is gonna be
it's gonna be a little bit more
difficult than I had hoped
mostly because of where these components
all live right right now like the
easiest way to do this would just be to
I don't know call call some of these
functions whenever we change the search
components right on the side drawer and
on the app bar
but unfortunately these aren't shared so
I'm gonna look Harshit saying you could
use get snapshot before update or get
derive state from props
okay you know what it I just got who
said it Michael Creole says was a
learning experience I've been playing
around with search trying to make it
work with graph QL still can't figure it
out that actually gave me an idea what
if all right let me talk through this
you all let me know what you think what
if we stored the search term in I can't
remember what it's called Apollo like
like a universal store right for the
entire application so I don't think
we've done that yet with Apollo though
but potentially I think that could work
let's see has anybody used that with
basically you use the capabilities that
Apollo has that acts kind of like Redux
right John Hansen says local storage not
I mean not exactly local storage we
could use local storage but I was
thinking more of what Apollo is let's
double check really quick Apollo it's
good Apollo graph QL to there Docs and
react
there we go local state management link
state that's what it's called
oh I should says since it happens on
route change using XJS route listeners
okay I like that idea let's check this
out
multiple reverses
I just want to go to the ghetto page
there we go
if you go to the next get up page you
can just do a control fine no events or
I'm route listener say route only see
other route area here's how to properly
listen for a router event and around
change router events on
[Music]
ichael let's try to listen to this then
and do we need to import yeah we'll
probably need to import router so let's
grab that first it's import router if
I've not already
yeah I'm not already doing this we're
gonna import router from next router let
me zoom in a little bit so the idea here
is if we could just use this to listen
for a route change we can trigger what
was already happening on component did
mount but instead we're gonna trigger
the same thing on a route change okay
so let's just copy what they have here
alright so the way this will go is on
the route change it's just gonna call
whatever function we give it and in this
case it's handled route change but for
in our case we're probably just gonna
call something we already have so I'm
gonna put this I'm not sure where we
need to put this let me double check put
this
I guess we can put it right out here
with with the rest of it I'm gonna try
to put it closer to the component it's
gonna call so hopefully it'll make more
sense so let's put it up here router I
thought we're importing router right I'm
using it
put it in component amount all right so
hard should say and put it in component
did mount Oh what did I just there we go
I think I accidentally copied the wrong
thing I said again okay we'll put it in
component did mount okay so that'll fire
this off one component didn't mount and
then we'll call we can pass component
amount to it interesting okay
[Music]
okay
I don't think I've ever tried to call
Component did mount this is gonna be
interesting to see if it works all right
oh yeah no property on of undefined
router events hmm that's odd right
because we this is exactly how it has it
here
I wonder if they have an example that we
can look at usually they have examples
let's check out these examples
with that let's go to our pages see the
index page maybe it'll have it on here
nope let's try here no I just want to
know where they have in the router
that's it there we are
use the next router here ok so they just
have router events here
ok all right let's just let's make a
little switch here let's take it out of
here
and we'll put it up here and then let's
do this is I kind of like I kind of like
this will pass in you are oh yeah let's
just pull this whole thing for now so
like how they're doing this so we're
gonna pass in I guess we don't really
need to pass in the URL right but we do
need to I didn't want to call multiple
things so we would call I guess these
three
and why again we have the weird squiggly
line on router hmm unless I see this
needs to go outside of here there we go
I'm not sure though if I'm gonna be able
to call these functions from outside
here let's see what error we get still
getting that same on air huh uh you know
what harsh is saying maybe I need to
update next j/s you know what you're
right I think I'm not using the latest
version
all right let's see how much time we
have oh okay almost time for Question
and Answer so we'll do some questions
and answers and then we'll decide
whether or not we're going to try to
update next yes right now definitely
gonna make another branch let's do that
right now get check out the search
update so I'm going to get check out
with a beef flag so that will make a new
branch and check out that new branch at
the same time I'm gonna call it search
update okay that way anything we do now
will not mess up our main master branch
okay let's I'm gonna do five minute
timer and answer some questions so I'm
gonna scroll to the top try to get
through as many questions as I can in
this five minutes and then we'll do go
back to do some coding okay someone's
interested in place on programming I
personally don't do any Python not on
the stream or anything but there are
definitely some other videos on this
channel where I use all different you
know types of programming languages so
maybe just do a little search for Python
inside the free code camp channel and
you'll probably find something let's see
see lot are you saying hi I'm not gonna
say all your names individually sorry
but I just want to make sure you have
enough time to get something done in
this stream
lovneet says is react good enough for a
job yeah for sure there are a ton of
react jobs out there
I see react in job listings all the time
like almost every day I see a job
listing for react I get them like sent
to my email and on LinkedIn and
everything so I see him all the time
Kranti says much appreciated for the
stream Thanks
I'm glad you said that I always loved to
hear that the stream is of value to you
all Stephen says howdy longtime viewer
first-time poster Oh awesome well thanks
for watching and thanks for let me know
you're out there Mike asked if I had
have discord I do have discord my name
is probably Jesse why go on discord it's
pretty much the same everywhere moose
moose feek says do you use PHP in front
of development do you have to use PHP in
front of development no not at all
PHP is not a front-end thing if you want
to do WordPress development it might not
hurt to know some PHP but otherwise I
really don't do much PHP at all Andrew
says hey if you're still in the market
for new keyboard I would recommend
something mechanical if you give me a
budget I could try to point you right
direction okay cool so for those of you
who follow me on Instagram you might
already know this but I'm looking for
suggestions for keyboards I have a new
setup at home that I'm working on and
I'm gonna maybe I'll show you all of my
new setup on Instagram if you want to
follow me on there it's Jesse dot LIGO I
think it's my name but I have this old
keyboard I really don't like how it
feels so I'm looking for suggestions my
budget right now it's like I don't want
to spend a lot on a keyboard I've never
used it of canticle one so I'd like to
get kind of like a lower-priced keyboard
I don't know like for sure under your
hundred dollars for a keyboard you know
maybe like around fifty would be even
better I know that's not a lot for
mechanical keyboard but I don't want to
invest a lot into one until I really get
the experience of typing on one and get
a feel for what I like and don't like
about them
see
did Jamal I'm sorry I'm not sure how to
pronounce SDG DJ ama elseís are you
contributing to react no I have not
contributed to the you know react
codebase but it'd be awesome to do so I
just don't have the time right now but
I'd love to at some point since I've
usually act for so much it'd be great to
give back
lovneet says how will I become like you
as a react coder
I just just practice and try to be
better than me right I'm not sure that
I'm like any type of goal to aspire to
but yeah just practice read
documentation build things with react
don't be afraid just build things and
don't worry so much just like is this
the right way to do it just build you'll
get better you can always go back and
refactor things but the most important
thing to get better at coding is is to
code code and try to improve every every
time you build something new try to
expand which you can do and build more
hey alright it looks like I'm not gonna
get through all the questions right now
but I will definitely try to get through
them on my after we do a little bit more
coding let me see I'm gonna write down
where I leave off so I don't miss
anyone's questions here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna start this timer for
another poet or a session but if we get
finished before it ends I'm just going
to go write the questions so we have
more time for questions okay I think
especially since we just made a new
branch I'm gonna try to update next on
on the air so I'm gonna go through all
the steps that I normally do when I
update like my major package that I'm
using so first let's go to next and I'm
gonna go up here to releases and let's
find out which release area so we're
gonna go to latest release so I'm not
going to update to one of these canary
cases they have all the latest features
but they also have more bugs than a
stable release so I'm gonna go to latest
for the release 6.1.2 and we're gonna
check out any release notes okay and it
looks like there's not see like normally
we would see they would say breaking
changes here and there's no breaking
changes so I think we're good to go
and it'll tell you usually we could
scroll down on most packages it's gonna
say it usually it'll say what to type
into to use this and actually mmm let's
go to the docs just to see if we have
this this ability and the latest stable
release
there we go okay so we can listen for
router events with the latest release on
route change start oh you know what it
has a different syntax okay you know
what let's just try this now I still
want to update next but let's see if
this syntax works and if it does at
least we'll have it working and then we
can update next if we want to okay so I
yeah we still need to import router but
now instead of router events on we're
gonna go on route change start and we'll
just copy and paste this stuff in here
get rid of this one let's see if this
works now we'll go back to okay we
didn't get an error this time which is
nice and all right that was a good sign
because it looked like it used what was
up here and it automatically search so
let's let's change this that was nice
okay that that's searching based on a
URL change which is awesome now here's
the next test we'll go back and do a
search for the okay and that didn't work
so this is still not working it did
update this but it updated it and in a
way that didn't trigger
accidentally click that so it didn't
trigger that on route change start so
let's look at how we're we're pushing
that route so let's go to the drawer
component since we we have it open
already and let me try see if I can find
search
I guess I could have searched for
something better
okay here's okay so we do a handle
search let's look for that handle search
okay so we're doing router push pathname
so we're doing a push
so let's look at the routes and see if
we could do this part in a different way
so that it would cause cause the event
to get registered right allows it to get
picked up so we're going to go back to
our documentation and I guess we use
this documentation although I really
wish there were a dark theme for this
you know it's killing my eyes routing
okay routing with link it's not what you
want to do not what we want to do yet
there we are so when you use this router
push that's right you may wish to listen
to pop stage react for the router does
refresh we could use
push it into place I'm gonna
double-check the chat to see if you all
have have typed in some advice okay
harsh it sang yarn upgrade interactive
latest might give you a heart attack
after seeing how many packages are out
of date I know I haven't updated any
packages for two or three weeks because
I knew launch was coming so I didn't
want to break anything too bad before
launch but I do want to start getting
things updated now because I don't like
to go too long without updating okay see
all right I don't see anything so let's
just keep on going with this
props you're a push okay so maybe
on before I was just for changing the
browser's history well let's see if we
change in the browser history actually
we are okay let's let's try this then
let's try to listen for a change in
browser history where am I we can get
rid of these two
yeah I mean we could try to listen for
this I don't I don't really know if it's
gonna work but it's worth a shot
and it means we don't have to change
that much
okay all right so let's see this now
let's okay so that didn't work either
let me I'm gonna refresh just to be sure
that it picked up that change although
I'm pretty sure it did okay yeah so
that's not picking it up either the
history
okay
all right what we could do we could
force it could force a change
so if we didn't use the router and we
just used the normal like browser API we
could potentially force a change right
we could try it too much time way over
all right so we can try try that or we
could try upgrading to the next version
of next and see if we then could use
some of the newer so actually you know
what we couldn't right so the
documentation we read it first on github
was for the canary release this
documentation is for the latest release
which is what we would be upgrading to
so this is what we would be using so if
we wanted to use the latest stuff we'd
have to wait until that actually came in
to the latest stable release so here's
what I want to try this would be the
last thing I try before we do some
questions because I don't want to I
don't want to go too long with the
coding and not be able to answer your
questions okay so we're gonna go to well
go to the drawer component for now and
instead of using router push let's let's
comment this out for now and instead
let's do window
location I'm doing this from memory
let's see if this works
equals
search search equals
okay so here's what I'm doing I'm gonna
use the browsers API to change the
window location and see if that'll
trigger anything I'm going for a memory
R so I don't even know if this is the
right way to say it let's see Serg okay
so I'm just using a template literal so
that I can put JavaScript in the middle
of this and grab this state so let's
save that see if we get an error or
anything
okay nothing right off the bat we'll let
this do its thing and then we'll try to
search from that side over there which
is what we just changed nice that worked
all right cool I do want to verify that
that changed the browser history it does
awesome so now let's just take what we
just did there and we can get rid of
that and we'll just take this and use it
in our app bar component so let's find
our app bar and find the search there
see if we have Handl search here as well
we do so we're gonna remove this router
push and put that in there we're gonna
save it and now oh yeah it works all
right cool
let's also verify the distant works
okay the one thing I would want to do
and I don't know if I'll have time today
to do that but you could see it I just
searched for biology here and I did get
the biology results but it didn't change
in the URL it still has the URL for the
other type of search so what I would
want to do then is make it so that when
a search happens here it does actually
change the URL so actually you know what
we can do for that let's do this router
push okay we're gonna do the router push
but we're going to put it in the search
so that when this happens to change I
guess I could put this on
try to figure out which which function
to put this on I guess we could put it
on this fetch search term I definitely
don't need a console of the search term
anymore so let's just pop this in right
here and see if that works
whoops property node is undefined that's
weird
didn't really change anything oops
you know I think we didn't bring in
router so we need to bring in router
whoops
there we go okay we do have a next rider
in there now so why is it not working
oops because I went to the wrong page
and hey I found another error so
academic Orange page does not work well
to write that down okay so let's do this
okay it didn't work what did I miss
probably let's see
let's put this somewhere else this said
states where is a search term
all right so when I grab the search term
after it's been set is a certian
okay so right here we're setting the
search term if the length width then we
want to do debounce search all right so
where's our debounce search let's see
bad city buses okay here's the bound
search and that just does fetch search
term which is what we were going for
we'll get results
so actually I mean this does seem like
the right place to put it no let's put
it back in here and make sure the state
search you know what I was calling it
search instead of search term that's
that's the problem there we go
there we go see it changed automatically
awesome that was the problem I was
trying to get it to give me something
from state that didn't exist in state
okay all right six minutes left all
right and I'm the while I'm answering
the questions I'm just gonna run do a
commit run it through the tests make
sure everything works check our status
if that looks good we'll do a get add
the yarn cm that's just gonna walk us
through making a good commit message
we're gonna add a new feature and let's
say change your searches so what we did
we changed the URL on all searches yeah
that actually that's pretty much exactly
what we did for the most part no
breaking changes as far as I know I
don't know if it affects any issues I
don't really want to check right now
Oh what happened
routers define but never used we never
took router out from our drawer and we
never took it out from our app bar so
you should be saved both of those now
what's running again we can run you're
in cm with a retry frag flagged and then
that way we don't have to go through all
that stuff that we just did well let
that do its thing I'll check back in on
in a minute in the meantime let me
scroll up to our left off for those of
you who may be just joining us the
coding portion of this is pretty much
over we're going to do question answers
if you have any questions please put
them in the live chat now I'll do my
best to answer all
of them if I can onk it says in what
language are you coding I'm using
javascript in particular I'm using react
and a syntax called JSX
react is a JavaScript library so that's
why I may look a little bit different
from normal JavaScript okay we passed
all our tests now I can push this get
push origins search update this looks
pretty good
I get minister lets kids check out
master
we'll do a merge get merge search update
awesome let's do a git push make sure
that goes up there and then we'll do a
test deploy let me double check what
that is test okay so let's run a yarn
test deploy okay that's going to do a
build and then it's going to do a test
deployment it's going to give us a URL
we can check it out make sure it's
working okay so that's going to take a
little while see
okay harsh it says that so I was talking
about a problem with builds not always
working or like it seems like they work
but in reality they were not working I
should say maybe it's due to lock files
make sure using properly using yarn had
a similar issue with natla fie is it the
same kind of build environment oh yeah
you know what sometimes I'm building on
my laptop and sometimes I'm building
here on this machine so it's possible
that it is the build environment off the
double check whoa that's weird
something happened she crashed
faculty is not found or not accessible
what is wrong with our faculty dodge is
that's really weird it should be here
looks good here all right let's run that
again maybe there's something wrong with
that bill see what's happening Mike says
hey mate is there any chance I can add
you in discord yeah yeah no problem
that's what I think it's Jesse y or
Jesse dot why go or something like that
on discord but maja says do you use
brackets editor now I use Visual Studio
code
[Music]
Kalyug says how are you good not bad I'm
I'm free I feel so much better now that
I launched this site it was really kind
of making me nervous
so yeah pretty good actually I started
getting back into working out on a more
regular basis going like some more
intense workout so I'm feeling really
good about that
so anyway how you doing well it air it
out again hmm
and he gave me a lot of info not
interesting
hmm
alright I'm gonna have to check that out
after the stream so I guess I'm not
gonna do a test deploy right now looks
just fine because we got a lot of
questions anyway
Kunal says how you do this I don't know
I just have learned how to do it and
practice yes
pratik says why react over angular I
guess at some point I wanted to learn
react and so I started learning react
and that's I mean that's pretty much why
I worked with angular 1 back in the day
and I had a hard time with it it was
probably just my inexperience I didn't
really have anything to do with angular
but when I started working with react
for whatever reason I I picked it up
more easily than I did angular and I
really liked it so that's kind of why
I've been sticking with react and I
think you can build really cool things
with with react Harshit says I have a
ton of experience with algo Leah but how
are you going to index the item means
you have a ton of stuff in WordPress
spread around
Harshit that's exactly what my concern
is is I like algo leah I've seen it in
use I think it's awesome but I don't
know how I'm gonna get it all the data
that it needs but I need to implement
something because the current search is
I mean it's not what I think people
would expect from search
you know when they search in Google it
tries to predict what the most relevant
search is gonna be so I need something
more like that and that to be honest
with you I'm not even sure if how goalie
is the right answer for that but I I've
heard really good things about it so
that's what I want to want to try
looking there first
okay Harsha says they have a great
WordPress plug-in just make sure they
support custom post types well if they
have a wordpress plugin this might be a
little bit easier so I do have on all
the WordPress posts I have the correct
URLs in there to handle the whole
difference between what WordPress thinks
the URL is versus what the react URL is
so I already have that data in there
that might make things easier space
Schiller says will you make a discord
server I'm not gonna make it this Court
server right now but there may already
be one we have a lot of different places
over you know the past year or so where
we've tried to get some chat going like
slack trying to think where else we had
forum once I can't remember the other
place where we had it so I don't know if
we ever had discord or not if we already
have something on discord and somebody
remembers please let me know in the chat
otherwise like I'm open to having a
discord server or for for the live
stream stuff but I'm not I just don't
have a lot of time to make it right now
girl ruff says I'm a first-timer here do
you have a github repo for this project
yet the link to the repo is in the
description Adrienne says hello how can
I put that yellow line under the head
function greetings from Spain yellow
line under the head function I'm I'm not
sure what you mean
so maybe clarify a little bit probably
because it probably made sense when at
that point but now I can't remember what
I was doing when you asked that question
so maybe explain a little bit more I'd
be happy to let you know doc yeah it's
Java Script react with JavaScript my
schoo says so lame apologies for my
lameness please let me know what I could
do to make this dream less lame always
trying to improve let's see
they'll dovakin says he sounds like Joe
Budden lol I don't know who that is
maybe I do sound like him I'm not really
sure Michael creo says you take two
weeks off and you forgotten how to type
I didn't take two weeks off I've been
working really hard I just didn't stream
for a long time I guess I forgot not a
type and talk at the same time a hundred
subscribers without a video challenge
says love you I love you too thank you
and good luck with your 100 subscribers
without a video
it's
so I'm skipping over some of this stuff
that was about what we were working on
earlier since we already got it to work
I don't don't really need to read it all
out
I need answers what's the current status
the site's launched now so it is live so
everything we're doing now is like bug
fixes or new features Gaurav says you
had dark mode on github how did you do
that
search for github dark on Google or
whatever search engine you like and it
should be one of the first results
Yousef says hi Jesse it's good to see
you again
oh thanks for saying that and thanks for
watching
I did miss you oh I I hadn't streamed
for a while and things were just so
crazy was trying to get it launched and
back and forth between everybody that
needed to be involved to make that
happen so I'm glad to be streaming again
though Eva says do you have live coding
streams about Redux saga I've never done
a stream about Redux saga so yeah I
don't have any plans to use Redux saga
right now if enough people were
interested maybe I'd I try to do
something a video about it or something
like that but currently no I have used
Redux thunks before and I may have done
a stream using Redux thunk in the past I
can't remember though it might be on my
youtube channel so I have my own
personal YouTube channel it's Jessie
white Jessie Ryo or Jessie wild
something like that it might be linked
in the description but I think maybe
I've used it on that channel I don't
really know but anyway redux thunk is
like usually seeing is kind of an
alternative to redux saga so it may be
similar
Marcio says would you call this session
a normal work day yeah yeah this is
pretty normal I guess yeah I would say
this is normal for like post
right yeah and the fact that I'm trying
to get it to work and I got to try a
bunch of different things would go back
and forth the documentation try it
that's that's definitely how things
normally work I mean sometimes I get on
a roll and like things just work
sometimes nothing works and I'm just
stuck in reading documentation and
trying things and going through error
messages and then you know everything in
between so I always says pretty pretty
normal the stuff you don't see is like
answering emails going to meetings
things like that I can't really put on
the stream or it would be boring to put
on the stream but when I'm actually
getting to do code this is pretty much
how it is also I do things like assign
tasks to other I have like student
workers and things like that so
occasionally I'll do little tutorial
videos for them in instructions so I
also do that as well
to Manya says that anyone have her catch
Jessie's Instagram handle it is I
believe it's Jessie dot why go okay
Michael Creole typed it in the chat so
you can see it in the chat Jesse dot why
go it's a Jes se dot WEEI GTL so I mean
like the little period not spelled out
Brian says how long have you been coding
in this language in with JavaScript I
think I've been doing JavaScript stuff
for like five years react two years
somewhere around two years I think
Phoenix says hey Jesse I thought that
this would be done since we are launched
websites are never done especially when
you work for a company and you're doing
the sites if you're a contract worker
like you're done when your contracts
done so I mean that's I guess kind of
nice but no the website is never done
well I mean we'll get to a point where
we don't really have to do a lot with it
and we move on to another project but
for now we're gonna be working on
updates to this for a little while
longer world boss says why don't you use
angular I because I know react I mean at
this point I know a lot about reacts it
would definitely be a step backwards for
me in terms of productivity to try to
learn angular I just I don't see the
advantage of doing that even in the long
run so if there's something about
angular that would really help out with
my projects and my workflow and my
efficiency then please let me know but
at least from what I know you know react
can fulfill all the requirements of what
I need for my projects and since I've
already been using it and can develop
faster with it then I can with angular
I'm just going to stick with 3x Michael
says okay Michael was having a little
conversation but I kind of like this
this comment so I want to read it
he says started looking for remote jobs
but impostor syndrome is kicking in hard
yeah so let me just comment on this
because I I know a lot of people talk
about imposter syndrome I definitely it
it hits me sometimes as well not as much
now as it used to especially since I've
been doing the stream because like when
you all keep watching me even though I
continue to mess up like it definitely
builds up my confidence in the sense
that like okay it doesn't really matter
how bad I am I'm like I'm still I'm
still useful for something as a
developer uh-huh
but when you're applying for jobs don't
worry about thinking what am I good
enough for this job that's not for you
to decide the other people that are
gonna hire you're gonna decide whether
or not they want you okay your job is
just to make yourself look as good as
you can with our line and get the info
out there right if somebody's gonna hire
you for the job then they're gonna hire
you if if they've hired you for some job
and you're entirely like not qualified
to do it and they don't provide you with
the training and you fail that's their
fault don't worry about it all right
it's just this is how it works right you
you are selling something and that's
your abilities in your talent so you
when you're selling something you make
it look as good as you can without lying
right the other person is going to make
that decision
based on a lot of reasons you may not
even know about whether or not they want
to buy what you're selling in this case
your your services your ability your
skills don't worry about whether or not
you're qualified or whatever you you
just got to put it out there that you
got something for sale okay so apply for
his money many things that you can I've
applied for jobs before where I didn't
even meet the minimum requirements it's
fine just and sometimes I've done that
and I've been able to actually talk to
people about the job you know
I may may never have gotten through to
like the full interview step but it's
still been a useful thing you know so I
encourage you to just just apply right
and don't don't worry about whether or
not you think you can do it Phoenix says
by the way Jesse I've created my first
blog site and I made my first blog on it
would you mind having a look at it on
the stream would love that feedback yeah
a Phoenix send me since you can't do
links on here haha you already sent it
on Twitter nice I was just gonna ask you
to send it on Twitter let's copy this
link address and you know what let me
get this ready and I will pull it over
oh cool
let me pull this over all right so this
is Phoenix's I lost my live chat where
did you go okay well I still had a live
chat up from two weeks ago Wow
okay this is the correct one right wait
is that still not the right one where is
the right chat
okay I thought for a second I closed out
the wrong chat window but I didn't
alright so anyway this is Phoenix's blog
really cool really cool I like this
where's my
this is really cool tool a I learned
soon as appose really cool I like this
that's cool thanks for sharing
I got like the thing I would say is in
terms of feedback just from a design
perspective since we're just looking at
it is maybe if you're gonna have shadows
you might maybe put a shadow on this as
well to keep it consistent like that it
seems like these are the same depth and
then also I usually don't like to have a
hover effects like how the shadow gets
you know longer unless something's
clickable so because it usually
indicates to the user the thing is
clickable you know not always but they
gets a common design pattern so you
maybe might not want to have that upper
shadow effect on this if it's not going
to be clickable but other than that I
think it's really cool and I kinda I
really like you got a lot of code in
there that's cool
let me see what it looks like okay so
this just goes down to the post nice
cool
gal Reve says did you use any other
boilerplate for react yeah this is the
next next Jas so it wasn't create react
up so yeah it will be different record
says I'm about to start learning react I
just wanted to know what I should know
about webpack es LAN Babel because great
react app contains everything but them
together yeah honestly if you want to
start with react and use create rekt a
few don't need to know anything about
webpack ESL and babble none of that
just worry about react down the road you
may want to customize some of that stuff
but you can definitely build awesome
things without touching any of those
things so I would just not worry about
it at all right now let's see
Yogesh says can you please share the
code on github yeah there should be a
link to this github repo in the
description to the video Kevin ward says
faculty JB versus Jay s ok so let's talk
about the errors we were getting
yeah that's that's a weird error
yeah I'm not I'm not gonna have time to
work this out on the stream I'll have to
work it out later event Allah says you
look tired I'm a little bit tired I woke
up in the middle of night last night so
I didn't get like a good amount of
uninterrupted sleep but not not too bad
mammy says hello I missed classes my
system crash with the help of a hacker
oh no I'm sorry to hear that I hope you
get everything back up and running Nicky
says I've been listening to a lot of
podcast recently headaches and not doing
anything kind of forced me to catching
up on lots of dead podcast what are your
favorites I like I don't think I'm gonna
be able to get to all the questions I'm
gonna try to go through this fast so
really quick I've been listening to the
syntax podcast
I think it's called syntax I like that
one I like the free code camp podcast
it's not exactly Developer one it's more
of like a hacking one but darknet
Diaries is really cool
I can't I know there's there's like
three or four other ones that listen to
and they're just slipping in my mind
right now so maybe I'll have to ask me
again when I'm not running out of time
maybe I'll look on my list of podcasts
and I'll tell you all the ones I'm
listening to Michael says you have a
chat window open for two weeks to go yes
yes I do evidently I do
John Hanson says server response time is
very good for all the database calls is
this because of specific headers sent to
the server is just because the site's
hosting an HTTP version - I don't know
really I don't know why it's fast it
looks like I accidentally skipped some
stuff yes as new to react any
suggestions for me just try to practice
a little bit every day you know what let
me check
I'm double-checking to make sure I have
a meeting in a few minutes so I don't
want to cut the stream off if I'm not
okay harsh it says we may have a discord
server we had Gator oh that's right we
did have Gator
all right so it looks like the other
people that are supposed to be on my
meeting are in another meeting right now
so it may have bought me a few minutes
so I'm just gonna keep streaming
okay Landrover says what's react use for
for building web apps you can also use
it for native apps and other things
vente lists is where should I start
learning coding free code camp
Harshit says now I get got why you're
getting build errors you're not you're
not shutting down the next Jazz
development sir so files are busy in the
file system and messing things up okay
let's see if this works then
oh okay so Phoenix says when the there
are more posts you will have to click to
expand so the hover effect alright that
that's actually perfect so if that's
going to be the case then I'd say yeah
for sure to keep the hover effect
Michael creo says how do you handle it
when you get 200 likes on a tweet my
flown is blowing up and it's getting
annoying
I don't know if I've ever had 200 likes
on a tweet so I don't know how to handle
it
Evan says just got here where do you go
for daily Co challenges actually I don't
sometimes I'll go to free code camp and
do stuff hmm okay I'm sucking airs
otherwise I don't really do their daily
code challenges ei houses hello change
your theme justice can you make a
project so we can learn maybe maybe like
on my channel I'll do something like
that at some point if I get time Gaurav
says you can share the list of podcasts
on Twitter okay maybe I'll do that
Josef's can you help me or us get a
coding job with no degree
yeah I'd say definitely try to go
through the free code and camp free code
camp lessons there are a lot of people
that have gotten jobs like that Harsha
says what are you using for that meeting
lookup I'm not sure what you're saying
I'm not sure what that refers to
Michael says that was a humble brag on
my part all right cool I think yeah I
definitely want to finish the chat up
now in case my meeting does start on
time I don't want to be late for that
cuz that's my boss and my boss's boss
are both gonna be in there
so yes I'm gonna finish up but thank you
all so much for watching it looks like
we had a lot of new people and so I hope
you liked it if there's anything I can
do to improve the streams please let me
know definitely welcome criticism and
hardship wanted to know how I knew other
people were meeting because I asked one
of my co-workers on slack
but yeah so anyway thanks again I'm
gonna try to stream again this week if I
can I want to try to get back into like
regular times for streaming and yeah so
hopefully I'll see y'all soon until then
have a great day